Shohei, what does this mean for the people back in Japan?
Japanese baseball, the kids that play baseball in Japan,...
...they always looked up to American baseball, big leagues.
So, this time we were able to win,...
...but not saying we're better than U.S. or anything,...
...but I think we got a little closer,...
...and I think all the people in Japan feel that.
Shohei, how does this moment compare in your career?
Is this the best moment in your career so far?
It's definitely probably number one.
It's got to be up there.
Like you said, it was like a storybook ending, storybook situation.
But more than anything else, I really appreciate this whole tournament,...
...this whole situation, this whole atmosphere.